what's up it's time for me to play a
video game everybody
this one's called mother simulator look
at what I goofy
gah there's poop on the wall ice on the
ceiling how's that even possible
select the challenge meet the baby okay
this is how the game begins
it looks like I'm about to take a snack
on the baby I don't look like much of a
mother alright it's baby time now I have
a timer so I best hurry
oh god that's awkward what do I do with
this oh he needs to diaper okay put it
down oh my god that's fine it's still
alive it won't be fine now I just got it
grab the thing and drop I did it I'm a
genie no wait it lost it alright grab it
and drop it
[Applause]
Oh grab it and drop it suck that thing
you stupid baby I worked before gravity
is said all right grab the baby oh my
god what's wrong with you
sit down whole bunch papa
something is wrong with my child
something is terribly wrong oh I know
what's wrong you need a little better
but oh well I gave it to em stupid game
[Music]
okay listen up kid we're gonna do this
one way and one way only all right sit
down let's just sit down that's right
and I suck it come on baby oh I can't
there we go
nope put it the controls are so delayed
like oh my god what a stupid face this
is not my child
they keep eat the thing today but it
ain't it butter your mouth what is wrong
with you you're going in the sink have a
timeout that's right you're going in the
sink you need to cool off what am I
doing wrong here it's German all right
are you gonna behave are you gonna
behave now
[Music]
okay what if I just get the pacifier and
I just gave that to the baby
what's your freaking problem but I got a
maybe hold it here take it take it don't
look at me like that Timmy Timmy what am
I supposed to do with you all right how
about this how about this I swear to God
all right how do I kill a baby do I need
to dip it in something so he will suck
it like maybe honey or something right
maybe that's it stop spitting it out
maybe I just need to keep giving it sob
i need instructions
[Music]
I got a watch [ __ ] I gotta watch that I
gotta wash it that's all I had to do how
do I get it in there I can't reach it
it's dirty it's dirty that's why oh my
god so how do I get it in there
there we go there we go I'm doing I'm
doing I'm doing it now here you go baby
and you go take act I don't have time
for your games baby yeah baby I just
realized it's my hat green cool now gift
from the baby is the next goal
it seems your robot kid made pee our
waterproof alter absorbent fireproof
nappy now taste some strawberries do it
so he can feel dryness and comfort easy
I'm a great mother every I make I'm
probably the best mother of all time all
right little Timmy
all right so meet you outside wait yeah
okay so what's step two step two what's
step one step two okay nope step two put
them in the bin
you get bonus point if I throw it from a
range okay huh can you be quiet I'm
trying to do the game here oh sorry
oopsie okay let's just drop it here no
I'm missing it every time afraid how do
I throw
[Music]
it doesn't it doesn't throw away this
game sucks alright grab the diaper throw
it in the thing okay and then be oh we
got to get the baby here come on to me
ain't got time ain't good time see me
alright guys sprayer how do I spray you
bit Timmy
sick Timmy go it thank you
[Music]
Timmy Timmy
there we go this is how it's done
[Music]
nope put them on did it I told you I
told you I'm a great mother people don't
recognize mix-up dinner
okay no problem I make excellent dinner
all the time all the time ask anybody
just watch me alright yeah i pacify you
need pacifier okay
all right so it's dirty so we need to
clean it of course clean clean clean
clean clean clean clean and then we're
gonna place it there perfect oh great
sturdy now that's fine all right we're
gonna clean clean clean cling cling
cling cling cling clean we're gonna put
it down here we gotta put it down there
look at that
alright just gonna just gonna grab this
there we go
all right a wee drop good thing that's
fine and just gonna put that down there
and we're gonna clean it again not a
problem we got plenty of time here I
gotta put that down there and then we're
gonna hit some water we're gonna grab
Timmy and Timmy's gonna get - oh my god
Timmy no Timmy's a demon cheats Timmy
please come back to us it's fine ignore
the demon baby we still have to make
water there you go thank you to be
wrapping out I really really appreciate
damn it it's dirty again
Timmy you suck god I hate this child
come here there you go sit down I'm
trying to be a good mother all right
dammit all right just fill it again fill
it again just fill it again we got
plenty of time Felix god dammit why does
it keep flying everywhere screw it screw
it on just say that Timmy you see that
you see I'm talking about that's what
I'm talking about
be quiet game oh my god Timmy Timmy stop
merging with things my god
sit down Timmy all right we're gonna
grab this Timmy it's feeding time Timmy
it's too far away all right put them
here are you kidding me
this game is rigged against you I swear
I'm a great mother all right let's try
this again water see the system is
rigged against our dads it's easy when
you know how to do it obviously so
what's step three what the heck is your
problem
you made it dirty I swear this kid has
an attitude problem I don't know where
he gets it from
Timmy eat the frickin bottle eat it ate
the bottle all right it's empty okay all
right I don't care that's right I forgot
of course it's empty or it's empty my
bad Timmy my bad all right so I'll just
I'm just god damn it all right goosfraba
we're take it easy we're taking it we're
taking it you see we're taking it you
got plenty of time we got plenty of time
don't worry Timmy I got you
daddy's got you
[Music]
all right daddy's got you Timmy daddy
loves you very much
[Music]
we got a minute
we've still got a minute put that down
nice and easy
the knives a nice clean clean clean
click 'ok like grab no grab it Timmy
Timmy you look a little down here you go
oh my god it got dirty because he's on
the floor go there Timmy I do not Timmy
I'm not playing games Timmy this is not
a game oh I gotta mix the baby powder
see me I'm so sorry I didn't know about
the baby powder who knew who knew kids
can't just you know kids kid are you it
will go in they will go in it will go in
I swear to God
Timmy I will murder you 20 seconds we're
doing this for Timmy god damn it all
right then it's good enough give me that
here we go here we go bro where are you
where is the thing
[Applause]
who would have thought it's so hard
shout out to all the moms out there I
had no idea just fill it up with water
and now we put it down and we add the
thing alright I assume it's in I assume
it's in no visual confirmation but
that's good enough here you go you
spoiled little piece of garbage don't
spit it out don't spit it out I will
kill it okay cool
[Music]
one now he wasn't stupid pacifier you're
such a stupid little child Timmy here
you go you dumbass
[Music]
hooray I have to look after myself it's
hard enough being a baby I mean having a
baby I didn't think it was possible to
hate babies more than I was already
doing myself all right so it's dirty so
we gotta wash it that's actually not a
problem but then apparently I'm hungry
as well all right here you go sucker
suckle nice big okay so let's have some
pie let's have some pie
let's have some cross zones some sweets
okay guys this is epic
and while we have spare time we can wash
up our stop oh my god I'm having the
time of my life who would have thought
being a father was this I mean mother
this being disregarding I feel like a
kid again what can I say look we're so
ahead
being a mother is easy it's easy it's
all it's always been easy anyone
complaining you don't know you haven't
seen you haven't played this game as
good as I have clearly don't hate the
player what do you want all right I got
your family I got you now what we need
here luckily I've already prepared for
this I know that little rascal would get
hungry that's fine okay fill it up put
it down grab this and don't make it fall
it gets good enough all right we got to
eat real fast bread bread and then put
this on and put that on Timmy Timmy
you're gonna love this you're gonna love
it it's empty
don't throw it we don't throw thanks in
this house
shoot I'm dying I'm dying berries we
just need the berries guy got 30 that's
fine that's fine we have plenty of time
boys we got plenty of time don't make it
fall over there we go it's it it's it
tell me your best eat this or I'll kill
you
what are you doing on the ground idiot
go back here here
that's right suck it up suck all of it
that's right
yellow all right once is pacifier where
is it where is it ah disgusting where's
its pacifier
I'm dying I'm dying any cheese sausages
[Music]
where is it stupid pacifier there we go
we're going for it boys
we're boy oh boy in for it boy suck it
suck it sit down now what now what
diaper no problem there you go damnit I
gotta do all that again are you kidding
me daddy don't love you okay I'm only
taking care of you because your mother
left you and I'm starting to understand
why you're useless you trash you're
nothing but a poopoo suck it
oh shoot I need to eat I'm sorry I
didn't mean to throw you I had no choice
oh my god no no okay all right we're
just gonna have to go with it oh my god
what is happening I don't oh my god
Oh God all right that's it that's it I'm
officially done being a mother put it on
oh my god I'm eat eat I get it yes Josh
slay Queen patty pie that's right I'm a
mother
how many nappies oh it's a robot kid
that's right that's right YouTube
that's right YouTube do monetization
it's a robot kid it's not a real kid
how many Nappers okay all right this
seems stupid everything else has been
anyway
all right it's time how do I throw them
[Applause]
all right throw them how do I throw them
I just throw you then oh come on
seriously I don't understand how you're
supposed to throw them I can only do the
mic drop
[Music]
you let your Lily oh I got it
good right click what
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah feeling like I'm
Jordan 3-point yeah I'm scoring
oh yeah come on I gotta hit some max oh
[Music]
oh oh my god I'm the best mom in the
world baby you see that timmy little
[ __ ] factoring oh I'll get dunked on bit
[Music]
join faze clan next look at it look at
it look at it son look at your dad food
poisoning
Oh No
[Music]
where's the freaking toilet here it is
it must be here Alexa this is a perfect
how do I put down the child normally
[Music]
okay and then a new pair of diapers
quite easily
Sam good assist I'm damn good at since I
was born to do
[Music]
this is really hard
look at this sucky sucky yeah yeah yeah
what you got what you got Timmy
you throw it in your own stupid face you
dumb ball diaper BAM
come here Timmy daddy's coming
yeah yeah
ice age are you kidding me Timmy it's
the I oh my god I'm sliding are you
kidding me
Timmy I ca I say why won't you just die
how am i how do I have water for my pad
this game makes no sense am i right guys
god damn it put it in its ice age I have
food poisoning and I have the worst
child of all time what the heck is going
on all right what does Timmy one now
diapers are no problem to me
[Music]
watch this Timmy whatever whatever it
doesn't matter you're irrelevant Timmy I
know I'm hungry game but Timmy needs a
diaper grab it come on Chabad this is
the play of the century crush on Barry
yeah yeah what next
Brad there's only one thing I can do hey
Timmy hey Timmy it's not so funny now is
it I was being a baby now smash like on
this video Timmy
or else thank you guys for watching this
video leave a like if you think I can be
a great mother and smash like if you
think I want I will be sure to read all
your comments and appreciated feedback
this has been mother simulator I'll see
you guys tomorrow with another video
sash and subscribe